yeah gervante looked good too I mean the
first round against Ryan I was like man
Ryan's kind of bullying he's bigger than
him and gervante made the adjustments as
a professional he is and and very very
skilled you can see his dedicated his
life to boxing and made the adjustments
and Stat running down finishing with the
body shot was it was a you know
beautiful performance for Javonte you
know I'm actually a fan I do talk [__]
on him I talk [__] on a lot of people
that are under 5'4 but that just is what
it is but he's super skilled yeah he's a
face of box right now do you know Ryan
at all do you and Ryan Garcia have a
relationship you guys would crush it
together whatever whatever content you
create training he's such a good dude he
lives up here man really good dude yeah
I've messaged him or we've messed back
and forth on Instagram a few times we
haven't really ever met or shot any
content together but yeah that's another
fight like that could be up there
eventually too and like I said about
that fight like that fight only happens
you know I have to at least be the
bathroom light champ potentially champ
champion and Javonte has to go out there
and keep doing his thing so we both have
to be major pay-per-view stars for the
UFC to allow something like that to
happen